foreign
i've got the signal on my screen that
we're live now
yeah we're now live chair thank you john
right good morning uh
fellow committee members good morning to
the
members of the public watching us on
council's youtube
site um just like to welcome to this
virtual meeting of
a special meeting of the plans committee
um
we've only got one application which was
wasn't determined at the last meeting
so we've got that this morning
at the start of the meeting i'll mute uh
we'll mute all microphones except mine
and please leave all microphones muted
unless you're asked
by me to speak residents who want to
exercise this right have been asked to
register in advance
and they've also had the option of
sending in a statement for us to read
out by the officer
or they've been sent a link to
temporarily join the meeting to speak in
person
we've got two persons who are registered
to speak today but i believe
one of them isn't speaking as center
statement instead
to indicate to me that you would like to
speak or propose or second emotion
please press
the raise the hand symbol in the
participants menu
on your screen these are shown on my
screen in the order
that they are pressed and i will deal
with them in the order giving the
appropriate
officer or counselor the opportunity to
answer
in between where necessary i will also
return to the council to check that they
are happy with the response
to ensure clarity and accuracy during
virtual meetings
all votes will be cast via a verbal
recorded vote
and names will be read out by the clock
in alphabetical order please state your
vote clearly
and slowly when your names read out
unmuting
and muting your microphone as necessary
please remember that to ensure full
transparency with the
democratic process this meeting is being
live streamed on the council's youtube
channel
as i mentioned at the start
i'll now ask um that everybody's patient
during this meeting
does take a little longer having to do
this vote
voting by recorded votes
and going through each member's name so
it does take a bit longer but i'll now
ask each committee member
to introduce themselves and also the
officers present
for this meeting so sandra if you'd like
to go through the committee please
thank you chair cancel about him
and i represent heartland
councillor brown good morning it's great
i represent great touring turn
councillor christie good morning i
represent
biddeford north
i don't think councillor craig is with
us this year
sorry councillor craigie
hi i'm councillor craig i'm ruth grady
from easter water in
belliford councillor leather
good morning yes councillor chris
leather and i represent northam
councilor mark yes good morning council
roosevelt
i represent two rivers and three moors
councillor mcgough good morning i
represent biddeford north
councillor watson yeah pete watson
broady
councillor wiseman richard wiseman i
represent the
shebian langtry ward
thank you chad thank you sandra and now
the officers
if they're if probably starting with
sean or and stacy
uh good morning members good morning
members of public my name's sean
harrington i'm the development manager
at toronto district council
morning my name is stacy dory i'm the
senior assistant and monitoring officer
at storage district council
good morning i'm helen smith development
management team leader at torridge
district council
i think that's everybody in that i think
that's everybody and sandra
sandra calls you of course is eric clark
for the meeting
that's everybody then right okay well
item one on the agenda is apologies but
i think everybody's here so
with no apologies apart from one of the
speakers i mentioned who's not
speaking but sent a written statement in
to be read out by sean
and two is declarations of interest
members with interest to declare should
refer to the
agenda item and describe the nature of
their interest
when the item is being considered
elected members of devon county council
and town and parish councils who have
considered a planning application
by virtue of their membership of that
council hold a personal interest
and are deemed to have considered the
application separately
and the expressed views of that council
do not bind the members
concerned who consider the application
afresh
item three is to agree the agenda
between spots one and two well there's
no part two
there is only one agenda item this
morning
item four is urgent matters i have no
urgent matters to bring forward
item five is public participation
and as i said there were two people
registered to speak
um for this application one was the
chair of the plans committee at
northumber
he's now sent a statement in which sean
harrington will read out an appropriate
time
and the other person to speak in support
of the application
at the hampton park application is
catherine knee
a member of the public who's speaking in
support
uh chair if i can just interject to that
stage i also have
a statement from catherine lee if she's
not available to attend which i can read
out
yep all right sean thank you
item six is the planning application the
information recommendations
and advice contained in the reports are
correct at the date
of preparation which is more than 10
days in advance of the committee meeting
due to these time constraints any
changes
or necessary updates to the reports will
be provided in writing
or orally at the committee meeting and
then we move on then to
6a which is the application one
oblique0460
oblique 2020 is a full application on
pages four to thirty five of your report
it's residential development at hampton
park
and this is brought back to
determination this morning
and helen smith is the officer helen
over to you to take us through this one
please thank you chair
um yes it's the the application
referenced is is before you now and
obviously on the agenda report the
application is made in full
and proposes residential development of
three dwellings
and associated works um the application
has been advertised as a departure in
recognition of the site's location
outside of
the defined development boundary there
are
no updates um that have come in no
further representations since the agenda
was published
so this is the the submitted site
location plan the application site
being shown in red additional land
within the applicant's ownership shown
in blue
the site is located to the north west of
biddeford however it falls within
the northern ward it is technically
considered to be countryside um due to
its location outside of the development
boundary
and as you can see from the plan it
already benefits from direct
access from rally hill which borders the
site to the north
and looking at an aerial photo of the
site now with the site
outlined in red um the the land
slopes downwards to the north towards
the a39
and hampton park is immediately to the
east
with the residential property sort of
fronting
onto this site and to the west and south
of the site is further undeveloped
countryside
just take looking at a wider context of
the site now the site is outlined in
sort of orange and pink
um just for members to appreciate how
the site relates to the built forms of
biddeford and northern
the the red dot on this aerial photo
is the scheduled monument lenward bowl
barrow which was which has been flagged
up by historic england in their
representations
this is an extract of the north evan
torridge local plan proposals map um
with the site outlined in red again you
can see that it directly abuts the
development boundary
you can also see that the the site is
not subject to any specific landscape or
heritage
designations as are shown on on the
proposals maps
now take you through some photos this is
a view from the north
west looking towards the site and
you can see um sort of the properties of
hampton park and that access road and
then
it's the field immediately to the west
and this is looking sort of from the
north further around to from the
northwest
and the boundary of the site
on the northern end you can see and then
the properties of hampton court
just beyond this
is a view you can't actually see the
site in this photo it just shows the
nature of the access road
um the site is actually just around
around that bend
and again this is from the other
direction so this is from the west
the the hedgerow on the right hand side
is the northern boundary of the site
now this is the existing access um field
gate
into the site now just entering into the
site with a series of photos this is
just immediately inside the access
looking to the south and
you'll see how the lambdas slope upwards
in a southerly direction
um this is looking from the south so on
a sort of higher
part of the site outside of the site
application boundary looking down
towards the north
the towards the east of the site um
it you can see the site is currently
used for equestrian
purposes um there's properties on rally
hill
and hampton park again this is the
eastern boundary
of the site and again further along
this is again the eastern boundary with
hampton park
this is looking further up in a
southerly direction
again so members can appreciate the
changing levels
of the land and looking around to the
south
west and then continuing around this is
the sort of the westerly view
the site and now back around
showing that northern boundary again
this is the existing site plan which
which
demonstrates with the the changing level
across the site but also that it is
largely undeveloped and lands in the
countryside
and this is the proposed site plan the
um
existing access would be utilized it
would be widened to achieve appropriate
visibility
into the site um an access point into
the field
beyond the south the retained field
beyond to the southward would be
would be also retained so that access
can still be made to that field
um the application proposes three
detached dwellings
each with their own car parking and
garden areas there's also a significant
amount of
um mitigation landscaping planting
which is shown particularly at the north
west corner of the site
and in terms of proximity to the
properties on hampton park
you can see that the nearest plot would
be plot one
and there's roughly distances of 29
meters and 37 meters respected
to those two properties on the hampton
park
just to give you an idea of the
distances
in terms of the design of the individual
dwellings
all three of the detached dwellings are
designed with
living accommodation at the upper level
um
utilizing a sort of bridge type access
to rear gardens again utilizing
the changing levels at the site um
each each property has an attached
garage
in terms of materials and render and
timber boarding will be used for the
walls natural slate for the roofs
with aluminium doors and windows so this
is plot one which is a three bedroom
unit
with a study plot two
which proposes four bedrooms and
finally plot three which is a five
bedroom
unit and then finally we have
um proposed drainage plan and
the site is within the kenwood critical
drainage area
the the applicant has submitted a
detailed drainage strategy
and drainage plan um and have evidence
that infiltration is not possible and
hence
they have justified connection into the
surface water
surface water drain um so
before you now are the material planning
considerations in this
case as set out in your agenda report
just quickly running through each of
these the principle of development
um given the council's current position
in terms of not having being able to
demonstrate a five-year land supply
this application must be determined on
the basis of the tilted balance
as as prescribed by the mppf um
whereby any any harm
must demonstrably outweigh any benefits
to
to justify refusal s policy sd 21 which
looks to
manage the supply of housing part two of
that policy is also currently engaged
and the proposal is considered to meet
the criteria within this
policy um um item
two there um design an impact on
character and appearance of the area
um with the significant landscape
mitigation that's proposed and it is
proposed to secure this via illegal
agreement and condition
um it's considered that the the
landscape harm
is not significant in this case subject
to that mitigation
that position has also been confirmed by
by two previous inspectors and our
previous landscape officer
i'm looking at heritage impacts the
applicant has supplied
um a statement in relation to the
lenwood bowl as as recommended by
historic england
and there are no objections from
historic england in that regard
and we um there's a recommendation for
an archaeology
condition as well to be included on any
any permission
um items four and five which relate to
residential amenity and highways
there's no technical objections on
either of those points
ecology 0.6 the the proposal
mainly due to the significant landscape
improvements and enhancements
can deliver a significant ecological
enhancement and
net gain which would be secured via
condition
and drainage as indicated on the
previous slide
there's no objections and technical
solutions can be
can be demonstrated for both foul and
surface water drainage
in terms of planning obligations the the
site just trigger
a need for an offsite open space
obligation which is set out within the
agenda report and this would be secured
by a legal agreement should consent be
granted
and then finally the planning balance as
indicated
a moment ago and set out in the report
the the proposal should be considered on
the basis of the tilted balance looking
at the
the benefits of the proposal and
weighing that against the
identified harm in terms of your
officer's recommendation in doing that
exercise and also having regard to
inspectors decisions that have
previously been made on this site
the recommendation is one of approval
subject to a legal agreement to secure
the landscape mitigation and the open
space contributions
thank you thank you helen uh
well the first applicant he would have
spoken would have been the
chairman of northern town council's
plans committee but
sean harrington has got a statement to
read out from
councillor kenny davis of northern
check sean harrington starting on the
public participation can i just clarify
for today's purposes there
were other public speakers who spoke um
in respect of the application on the
third of september
some of them haven't come back today and
registered but those are still valid
and members are still invited to take
those representations into account
all right thanks jason
okay chair
uh so the written statement on behalf of
kenny davis
uh chairman of northern parish council
northern plans committees now regarding
rally hill
my council being norman objectively
proposed development
unless things have changed as far as i
know this sighting question is outside
the development area
one of the main reasons it was called in
when i
sat where you sit now for then it was
defined as being in the open countryside
and outside the rural development as we
all know
at the heart of the national planning
framework there is a presumption in
favor of sustainable development
which should be seen as a golden thread
running through both plan making and
decision taking
and we at northern are concerned that if
this said gold and fred
the show to run through this application
then we see no reason to deny housing at
the edge of the new settlement boundary
thereby weaving its way until all the
fields up to the link road
and mount its web and filled with houses
and to be honest we realized the new
level plan
has been voted on and been accepted but
norman was getting rather fed up with
being filled up
but in the balancing act of things this
would be known as nimbyism
however judging by the sustainability
principle of the mvpf
in my opinion the free dwellings applied
for which contribute very little
to the local good
for as we all know there are three
dependent elements
which planning must fulfill economic
social and environmental
other than individual interests perhaps
there is no defined village or community
close by to which the development would
contribute to society
that the site would be next to a
residential area which has no
infrastructure or common community
facilities in place
the recent mission granted for 180
houses
nearby in the valley parallel to raleigh
hill makes its present application for
three houses unnecessary
and highways terms the traffic generated
from 180 houses will make access along
rally hill
more congested we note that 30 feet of
hedge bank would be removed and this
will constitute a loss of habitat
and hence biodiversity for birds and
small mammals and the policy env1
while the construction of houses will
narrow the green corridor between
the existing development and the link
road in conclusion
this proposed development would severely
alter the character of the area
characterized by a narrow
a narrow country lane rolling green
fields and thick hedgerow
and we urge you to refuse the
application k davis
thank you sean and the next statement
then
that we have is from the from catherine
knee who's a supporter and she's written
she sent a statement in as well if you'd
like to read that actual
sure written submission by on behalf
catherine the
uh collier planning the agent for the
application
members given your officer's
comprehensive report and to
avoid repetition we did not make
representations at the last committee
meeting
however having listened to the
discussion at the previous meeting we
wish to make the following brief points
the first appeal was dismissed at a time
when council did not have a five-year
housing land supply
due to the inspector concluding that a
legal agreement was necessary to secure
the delivery of the proposed landscape
mitigation
any planning permission granted today
would be subject to completion of a
legal agreement to secure this
the first appeal inspector said the
proposal would have
the social and economic benefits of
making a contribution to address the
current supply of housing
and make a contribution to the local
economy
the second appeal was accompanied by a
legal agreement but dismissed because
the council had
just adopted the new local plan and so
were at that time
able to demonstrate a five-year housing
land supply however
as members understand the current
position is that the council does not
have a five-year-old supply
it is clear from the previous two appeal
decisions that subject to proposed legal
agreement to secure the delivery of
proposed landscape mitigation
both inspectors indicated that the
planning balance weighs in favor of
permission being granted
when a five-year housing land supply
cannot be demonstrated
officers will be aware that the
government's planning practice guidance
specifically encourages local planning
authorities
to avoid persisting in objections to
scheme an inspector has previously
indicated to be acceptable
thank you thank you sean
that's the last of the speakers on this
application
uh so it's now open to the committee for
debate
councillor mcgough you're first
thank you mr chairman um last time i
proposed this application
chairman and i will propose this that we
grant this application again
like it did in a previous one um
agreeing with the officers report that's
before us
thank you thank you councillor
wiseman you're next to speak please
thank you chair
i thought councillor locke was before me
you know well council locks now come up
on the screen
councillor locked then and then
councillor wiseman yeah i will second
captain mcgoss um recommendation that
the application is approved because i
listen carefully to what
northern town council have said and they
talk about creepy development because of
course we can't even consider that
because we can only consider what is
actually in front of us today
but i've got one question really for
helen um
and i don't know it's a legal one or not
i mean the applicant has known
that he's got to draw up a legal
agreement for
various things why couldn't he have done
this beforehand
and made it part of the application or
does the process
can the process not work like that
because our c permission is granted
subject to that
agreement so i would have thought he's
had two bites of the cherry and if he
put that
in with his application it might have
been better
yeah um chair if it's okay i'll respond
to cancer looks
locked question um in terms of the
second
appeal because if a legal agreement is
is required in respect of an appeal an
applicant has to
provide a signed legal agreement by the
time an inspector makes a decision
so a unilateral undertaking was prepared
to secure the landscape mitigation as
shown on the plan that's on your screen
now
um what has now materialized given that
we we have an adopted local plan now and
can apply
the principles of policy dm10 which
looks to secure
open space um there is now an additional
requirement beyond just that landscape
mitigation and that is for open space
contributions so
as we would on on you know on the vast
majority of applications that require a
legal agreement that that legal
agreement is
is finalized post committee so so if it
was just the landscaping that was to be
secured yes certainly
we would have a assigned unilateral
agreement that would be you know
available for members to look at however
that that
legal agreement does need to be amended
should consent be granted to
to secure the open space okay
thank you for that response but i will
still um the second council of god's
proposal
thank you councillor wiseman then uh
thank you chair um
i've been uh i'm not that familiar with
rally hill so i went there and had a
good look around spent quite some time
looking around
i think these houses are very much in
keeping with all that all the
neighboring properties some very nice
properties up there
it comes down to our five-year land
supply as we all know and
i can't see that the harm of this
development will outweigh its benefits
so
i'm quite happy to support it
councillor christie yes it's interesting
isn't it
uh hearing all these different views um
let's get down to the planning issue
shall we because that's what this is all
about
uh if you look at the history of this
site we've turned it down twice
already he's been to appeal twice
and been turned down and the only reason
it's come back now is the five-year land
supply
but this is an issue where
the inspector last appeal
the second one has actually highlighted
the real problem
if you turn in your agendas to page 27
page 27 this is the inspector's reasons
for turning down
the application at appeal look at
paragraphs eight nine and ten
eight starts off as the site is outside
the settlement boundary it is to be
treated as being in the open countryside
he then quotes our local plan policies
number nine irrespective of the close
proximity of the site to the settlement
boundaries of biddeford
it is in the countryside outside of the
area
number 10 in view of the first main
issue i find that the proposal conflicts
with the strategy for the location of
new housing
development i.e it is in the open
countryside
you look at this site it is surrounded
on three sides by fields
and i don't care what the house is going
to look like
i don't care if it's going to meet our
five years land supply
this goes against our local plan
and if you vote for this you really are
giving in to this idea that every
application that now comes in because we
haven't got a five-year land supply must
be passed
it's ludicrous to vote for this because
we've voted against it twice we look
silly
if we vote for it now why
nothing's really changed i am going to
vote against this
and i would urge councillors who've said
that they're going to vote for it
just to look again at the planning
inspectors findings on this
thank you thank you council christy
councillor craig
thank you can you hear me yeah yeah okay
thank you um i'm very grateful for
councillor christie for what he said
because
i've been struggling a bit with this one
and um
i i was trying to find a reason to vote
against because as you recall i've
gained last time um i've looked at it
very carefully i've studied it
in detail because i didn't feel last
time i knew enough to make a decision
but i think what council christie has
said
has convinced me that there there is a
legal reason to object so i'm going to
object this time
thank you thank you councillor craig
well nobody else has got the hand up the
minute so
councillor watson yes thank you chair
well i'm going to go against what
council of christie says because i
i won't change my mind from the last
time
we have two inspectors reports yes it
does talk about open countryside
but let's put a cast iron mines back to
to how old junction if you look on
google maps
our junction the site there that we
approved
is an open countryside and if you look
on google maps
it is in a very similar situation as to
where
this one is and our two inspectors
one of the first one didn't approve it
because
we had we had no maintenance
and management plan the second one did
but then we had a five-year land supply
so in my honest opinion
we need to be consistent if we can
approve
we've got to look at each application on
it i understand what i
understand that but we need to be
consistent
and approving how well in a similar
situation to this and petrox though
it just makes a mockery if we don't
approve this
the inspector is the two inspectors
reports
and his conclusions are a material thing
towards this planning application and
therefore i i'm sorry i will be going
for it
answer the lot you want to come back
yeah i just come back on what um
counselor peter christie said
um i do have to disagree with peter if
we approve this one that means we've got
to approve every application that comes
in
because you know because we haven't got
a five-year land supply well that's what
council watson just said
yeah but i mean every application on its
own there just like you said
just because we might approve this one
doesn't mean to say that you're going to
approve every application
on the grounds of no five-year land
supply
thank you council a lot excuse me chair
but i didn't say
that we had to approve every other one
on a five-year land well you said we had
to be consistent
yeah because you quoted two had been
approved
therefore the way you were talking it
sounded as if everyone's got to be
approved
no no and as i said we've got to look at
each application on its merits
thank you very much thank you right
there's no other hand up so
i will have my say on it um
as it's been mentioned before twice two
plans committees
one in the old council um i think 2018
was the first one
twice even with officers recommending
approval refuse this application
and as has been said twice on appeal
it's been refused
what what i'd like to see there's been
no sequential test of this site for
housing
when just down the road we've got a
strategic site
for 210 houses on a 10 hectare site
just behind up rally hill so there's
absolutely
no need in planning terms to have this
site developed in the open countryside
and it is open countryside and as has
been pointed out we've seen it from the
presentation
it's surrounded by fields on three sides
um nmr9 is the one i just referred to
you're going to lose a long stretch of
hedgerow here
to widen this entrance to the side
and at the bottom of page 11 it does say
this tilted balance
some members do seem to think because we
haven't got
currently the five-year housing land
supply
that so it must charge just a minute
bottom of page 11. i just want to read
that's all i want to do thank you
i did say bottom of page 11. it does say
this tilted balancing for the purpose of
the
presumption policies of the development
plan
are not considered to be automatic date
of date
by virtue of not being able to
demonstrate the high five-year
housing loan supply whether a policy of
the development plan is out of date
is a matter for the decision taker in
the light of their substance
and considering their conformity with
the mppf
and the and the north dakota's local
plan
so uh as i'm councillor christie said
just because we're not currently able to
show this five-year
housing land supply does not mean every
single development that comes forward
are joining the development boundary in
torridge has to be approved
and this has been turned down as i said
by the
northern town council twice torres
district council twice
and two planning inspectors councillor
christie did read out
on page 27 which i'd highlighted also
eight nine and ten policies st06
and st07 this is contrary to both those
policies
and that's a re that's the reason it
should be refused on
it is open countryside and
also on page 28 the inspector said
the development of the appeals site
would not make a significant
contribution
to the supply of housing in the plan
area and therefore i have
afford the benefits limited weight
limited weight
that's the inspector three dwellings
there and
i heard what council wiseman said they
might look very nice dwellings
that's nothing to do with it it's the
fact of development in the open
countryside
that's the crux of this so
i'm certainly going to as i have all
along considering this one
i shall be voting against support for
this councilor watson
yes jeff also on page 28
planning balance and conclusion i have
concluded above that the subject to the
implementation of the landscape and
secured
by the undertaking the development would
not harm the character and appearance of
the
of the area so
thank you for and again counselor
wiseman
thank you chair um yes the the appeal
decision
um 28 paragraph 15
it says the council is able to
demonstrate the five-year land supply
and then it goes on in this context of
the development
um he he thinks it doesn't
contribute well it will because it can't
can it if we already had a five-year
land supply it couldn't contribute to
the five-year land supply
we don't now it's very different the
whole thing sort of hinges on this issue
really we don't have a five-year land
supply
therefore my belief is the planning
inspector would look at that very
differently
and he would now think it would
contribute to numbers
we've got to bear that in mind yes
but as i say as i said at the beginning
when i spoke bottom of page 11
for the purposes of the presumption
policies of the development plan
are not considered to be automatically
up to date
by virtue of not being able to
demonstrate five-year housing land
supply
we've had a proposal from councillor
mcgoff
to to grant this application and it was
accepted by councillor locke
and there's nobody else wanting to speak
on this so i think we'll go to the vote
on it
cassandra could you read the committee
in alphabetical order please
on a proposal to grant this proposed by
councillor mcguff
sent me back councillor yes thank you
chair
councillor bowton
uh four councillor brown
four councillor christy
against councillor craigie
against hanson leather
against councillor locke
on meat road
four sorry hansel mcgough
four pencil watson
and councillor wiseman or
that vote is six four and three against
emotion chair
thank you chair uh thank you sandra
right we move on with our agenda which
is part
a generator so that one's approved then
six books to three
um a ginger item seven is part two there
is no part two
um that being the final
uh item on the agenda this morning i
declare i'm meeting
close thank you for all those who've
attended and thank you for
whoever is on youtube watching this
plans committee meeting
hope you find it interesting thank you